[موسيقى]
رقصات جماعيه واغان فلكلوريه واجواء
احتفاليه صاخبه الطقوس تبدا باشعال
النيران لتنطلق بعدها احتفالات يستمر
بعضها لايام انه عيد النوروز لدى الاكراد
هذه الاحتفالات الصاخبه يحييها اكثر من
اربعين مليون كردي حول العالم سنويا في
عيدهم الذي يصادف في الحادي والعشرين من
شهر مارس
طقوس الاحتفال تبدا مساء اليوم السابق
للعيد حيث تضرب النيران ويبدا المحتفلون
بالرقص حولها
كلمه نوروز تعني اليوم الجديد وفيه يتساوى
الليل مع النهار معلنا نهايه الشتاء
الطويل وبدء فصل الربيع
اسطوره العيد الكرديه تعود الى ثلاثه الاف
سنه يقال انه كان هناك ملك ظالم يدعى
ازدهار او الملك الضحاك يملك ثعابين على
كتفه وفي كل ليله يطلب طفلا من اطفال
الكرد ليقدم دماغه لتلك الثعابين الى ان
وصل الى اطفال حداد المملكه الذي يدعى
كاوا الذي قرر وضع حد لظلم الملك الضحاك
وعزم على قتله اعلم كاوا سكان المملكه
بانهم اذا شاهدوا النار فذلك يعني ان
الملك الظالم قد قتل وهو ما حصل فعلا حيث
تسلل الى القصر وانقض على ازدهاك الظالم
وقتله ثم اشعل النيران فوق قصره فكان
النورس يوم الخلاص من العبوديه وبدايه
الربيع
بالعوده الى طقوس العيد وبعد اشعال
النيران يبدا الاكراد في اليوم التالي
بالخروج الى الطبيعه حيث الاحتفالات
والدبكات والاغاني الفلكلوريه ترتدي فيه
النساء لباسا تقليديا مزركشا بالوان
الطبيعه يتالف من ثوب طويل يغطي في الغالب
الى اخمص القدمين له كمان طويلان يسميان
في اللغه الكرديه بكراس وخفتان اما الرجال
فيرتدون سروالا فضفاضا يسمى شروال وستره
من اللون والقماش نفسيهما والله عدنا وروز
هي عيد كل الاكراد
وعيد يعني هاي العيد كل الاستقلال الاكراد
من قبل قبل اجدادنا لهلا كلنا عم نفتخر
فيه او بنطلع فيه وين ما كان
بكردستان ولا باي باي مناطق حتى باوروبا
وغير اوروبا كل الاكراد بيحتفلوا بهذا
العيد نوروز
الاكراد ليسوا وحدهم من يحتفلون بهذا
العيد اذ يشاركهم بذلك الفرس والباستون
والاذريون ويبلغ عدد المحتفلين به حول
العالم نحو 300 مليون شخص من الشعوب
الاريه بحسب اليونسكو التي ادرجت العيد
على قائمتها للتراث الثقافي غير المادي
الاحتفالات تتشابه الى حد كبير لدى بقيه
القوميات والاعراق ويعتبر يوم الحادي
والعشرين من مارس عطله رسميه في اغلب
بلدانها التي تشمل سوريا والعراق وتركيا
وايران اضافه الى اوزباكستان واذربيجان
وتركمانستان وطاجكستان وكازاخستان
وقرغستان الى جانب مقدونيا وجنوب القوقاز
والقرم ومنطقه البلقان وكشمير وولايه
كاجارتا الهنديه وبعض الباحثين التاريخيين
يرون ان السومريين من اوائل الذين اختاروا
تاريخ النوروز ليحتفلوا به كبدايه لتقدي
مهم وهو اليوم الذي كانوا ينصبون فيه
ملوكهم وحكامهم